[Music]
all right so sort of couched around
everything we're talking about so far is
is sort of good and evil the tactics
that some people use to be involved in a
conversation the motives that we had
whether it be because you're a believer
or a non-believer right now I've come to
a place where I think right now in 2017
we're in a strange spot where they're
setting the the institutions that used
to help us keep some of this stuff in
the lanes what what is acceptable what's
not acceptable what's right and wrong
what's real and not real you know
whether it's true or not that these
institutions are crumbling and by that I
mean that media is crumbling our
political institutions seem to be car I
can run our academic institution so
that's the way I only want to get into
with you
all of these things are starting to
crumble it's partly because information
has changed so much I would are they
didn't even worse than crumble but what
you would say they're they're decimated
already no no I would argue that the
academy certain sections of the Academy
the sciences I think they're doing very
very well
the humanities are in shambles certain
departments anything tainted by
post-modernism particularly Gender
Studies the conceptual piece okay so
everyone's rejects okay let's just go to
the conceptual penis as a social
conscious as a social contract right you
will wrote a hoax paper with James
Lindsay right and you got this public
that we thought was extremely funny it
it I mean I read it it's jaw-dropping ly
ridiculous yeah and argued for climate
change being responsible to conceptual
penis yeah and I thought it's always
funny as a satire sort of the main
takeaway of it is that the penis is not
really a real thing it's just this sort
of amorphous idea and we threw in a lot
of moral jargon we threw in all we
appeal to their moral sensibilities okay
so why P you're an academic why would
you write a hoax paper why would you
mock the very institutions of which you
are maybe cuz I think that there are
departments in the Universities that are
making a mockery of our institutions so
when you said crumbling I don't think
that's that's not the word I would have
used although it's accurate in a sense
but these people are
advocating not only their own knowledge
bases they're writing things in journals
that they then fight that becomes
knowledge they have their manufacturing
ideas that are totally untethered to
reality this is how crazy this is
so let's look I'm going to explain it
I'm going to try applying this you real
me and if this is unclear okay but this
is idea is so crazy that anybody
listening to this exams that can't
possibly this this can't possibly trip
so this is the idea and then I'm going
to give you you're asking you a belief
I'm going to give you an analog and
theology okay so what these people do is
that they have moral intuitions based
upon Marxist thought basically I'll get
to that a second so what they do to
justify this is they manufacture their
own epistemology their own way to know
that justifies the conclusions that they
have so then they can go out and become
activists now quick detour yeah one of
the biggest problems facing the left
right now is anybody who calls out a bad
idea is viewed as somebody on the right
we've got to stop that I know a little
something about you know a little
something about this yeah a lot about
this so let's i'ma give you an analogy
in theology so this guy alvin
plantinga's is a Christian philosopher
so he has these beliefs these they are
actually one that they're claims about
reality and about Jesus being the Son of
God so he realizes that there's no
evidence that can take him they're
usually so what does he do he
manufactures his own epistemology he
said well you know we're going to say
that there's this thing called the God
center and the god center some people
have it and it allows you to just as I
apprehend the color red so to do I
apprehend God so he makes an
epistemology to justify these insane
claims about the nature of reality so
just as he has done that critical theory
is that epistemology that is used and I
can explain that is complicate I'm a
friend of Louie we're all right we got a
lot of terms we're going to throw out
either a very complicated
what I would like to attempt to do in
this segment is to link the madness on
campuses right now to the intellectual
engines driving that madness and and the
make no mistake about it these
departments tainted by post-modernism
are absolutely filled with zealots and
morally motivated either ideologues
okay so let's so I'll do a little catch
up so that in case anyone's missing in
it
so first let's let's talk about what is
post-modernism I know but I know most I
don't know that but let's just let's
just do a couple definitions quick okay
so that's the definition so okay so the
Frank ports Frankfurt School has this
idea of but let's even go backward let's
go back to Karl Marx Karl Marx was a
philosopher oh here's a bonus question
why did Hitler hate call Marx I feel
like there's a good punch line well it's
not a joke such as you can no Jew
anything the Jews touched work Oh God in
there but other ways in it a lot easier
either they were great guy no no okay so
so Marx Marxist economics and these
people aren't Marxist they're more
Marxian would be a better term marci
economics looks at the world in terms of
economic oppression there are oppressor
classes etc so they have and then we'll
get to the idea post money is very it's
as simple and complicated so they've
taken this idea of these Marxian notions
of oppressor classes and look at them in
terms of gender and race and for example
the patriarchy and then they have
hierarchically prioritized people within
that list so the patriarchy is white
heterosexual cisgendered which is the
thing males and they want her at the top
of it or a bag the [ __ ] I am absolutely
thought a there and but that's the other
thing they do just like religion they
have their own defense mechanisms and
that's what they say well you can't
criticize it because you're a
cisgendered white heterosexual male and
is the ultimate irony of this that is
prejudice that is prejudging ah because
okay because I
I then sit here and go wait a minute
okay here bagozzi and a white straight
cisgendered male yeah I really judge you
based on your immutable character this
is indispensable talk about so you are
using words based upon normal ordinary
definition I'll give you example some
more it's like so when you use racism
it's the way I use root to it most
people who aren't in haven't been
indoctrinated by gender studies in the
postmodern left it's the idea that you
do not judge people particularly
negatively but you don't make judgments
about people based upon an immutable
characteristic like their skin color but
they've changed that definition to make
it systemic racism they've changed that
definition to put in a power vector that
a hierarchical power vector that only
flows one way so for example and this
blacks cannot be racist against whites
so they have snuck it's very sneaky
they've taken a normal word it added a
moral component to it and change the
definition of a word you know here's
some if I may give you some more
examples like equality equality is a
good thing but they have shifted from
equality to equity now what is equity
mean equity means well we need a certain
number of people representative of the
general population seventy percent
african-americans we need to have
seventeen percent but the problem is
that that that they also want to take in
to account historical discrimination and
a kind of reparations for that so those
numbers are even higher so it's I think
it can be summarized in Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's quip or joke where there is
how many female Supreme Court justices
you think there should be nine so it's
not just right it's not just that we
want equal representation higher we want
more because of past and justices go
ahead because this is this get we got to
talk about deconstruction we got to talk
about violence we can talk about why all
these things when you understand them
from this mindset they're all coming
from the same school of thought affected
by critical theory that's why the most
about let's define
critical theory yeah so critical theory
is this idea that you that traditional
power dynamics and traditional and this
is oversimplified but it's a general
idea from which we can have a starting
point for a conversation yeah see that's
again I thought to myself I'm going to
get 500 emails says it and just China
and it makes me again it makes me self
sensor and then I'm like come on yeah
okay but that's real that's a real I
want to get lost now yeah that is a real
thing I mean I find it for myself
sometimes I try to talk broadly about
things because I want to communicate big
ideas and hopefully people will then
read some books or watch some other
videos or I follow some other people on
Twitter or whatever and then even if you
talk about it will be well you see he
yeah he wept over that right or in
another time why didn't he talk about
the Frankfurt School like we didn't
mention Horkheimer what's our door know
all these guys are left guys and you
know just you just get to a point where
all of that is centering it's
essentially just it's not it diminishes
the message it's not good for you it's
not good for conversations it's not good
for okay so anyway XY I mentioned with
Inquisition and I think that was an
either
yeah or into that will Inquisition right
now if you think for yourself and you
are not afraid to buck the trend you
know will come to get you it's exactly
the time right so critical theory so
it's the idea that the it's basically a
Marxist idea it's the idea that there
are these entrenched power structures
and entrenched power dynamics and one of
the things that we need to do is we need
to recognize these and then we need to
over those we need to deconstruct these
traditional hierarchies to make society
more that's to thing more equitable more
fair more what is it what is it it's
complicated
so these kids protesting and evergreen
or have they don't just ex nihilo just
get this idea that they just going to it
just it no they get this these are
coming out of specific departments in
the university and when they're asked
you know why do you do this or what is
this they tell my professor said this
and then this is the the insane part
that gets back to the conceptual be
against that these people have their own
lines of literature that is these are
intellectual cesspools to him that's
going to get no so they have your egg
and all right whose side are you now
yeah that they have manufactured what
they think that's why they have to like
with cultural appropriation they have to
import ideas like power because it isn't
if the whole thing is made up it's
completely fabricated because they want
to use they want to overthrow these
traditional hierarchies so these kids
get this idea from their professors who
then get promoted and tenure because
they publish in journals and their stuff
is almost never cited by anybody but yet
that's how you rise up and then what
happens is you have a whole canon of
knowledge and you go out and teach
people and and then you have diversity
training and the the shame of this whole
thing is that there is legitimacy to
white power
there is legitimacy to some of this
stuff but the way that it's metastasized
almost doesn't allow any kind of
liberation it does almost the exact
opposite of what they want to do because
it gets you people like Trump but one
more thing was saying yeah but but then
what happens is it goes to colleges of
education and then they start teaching I
think I told you my son has in his
geography has geography civics a camera
where I look at stuff he doesn't they've
never even opened a map they've never
opened a map they've never in civics
class how many Supreme Court justices
legislative branch mommy sent none of
that stuff but he knows everything about
the Black Panthers but is everything
about the civil rights the civil rights
movement is extremely important
wonderful stuff but it should not we
need to look into that we kids need to
know what country's above Canobie really
all of this stuff gets back to certain
departments in the university that are
pumping out nonsense that are
indoctrinating people and exactly like a
religion they have their own defensive
structures they're you know being
offended is the new thing inclusion is
in other words that they've changed the
meaning of so there is a direct line
between is this coming is
clear so far may be clear to me yeah
okay so there's a judge with the
audience okay so because if it's not
clear something needs to Paris or they
want to overthrow these traditional
hierarchies and they've manufactured
their own base of scholarship to do so
so however why it's worse than crumbling
because at least if something crumbles
something worse didn't take its place
like if in a lot like it's like you're
having an alarm clock that rings
randomly so it's worse than just having
an armed clock that doesn't work if
they're pumping out fabricated nonsense
that's totally untethered to reality and
the moment you call these people out on
it they don't believe in dialogue anyway
they'll still slander you the write your
name on the bathroom wall they'll scream
at you so the only thing to do you got a
hoax in it you've got to have a
non-traditional way to deal with people
who are so fundamentally irrational that
they're not going to have a conversation
I that led you to writing this hoax yeah
and turning this thing on its head
all right there was so much there when I
get to so first off what's the
connection with the religious-minded
bond until had wonderful it strikes me
as the new religion that in a very right
politics but but this leftist postmodern
Marxist oh that this is the new religion
they they monitor before everyone else
for their beliefs
all right but they have a belief that is
so tethered to their own being that if
you challenge it in any way they out
care well they'll hate you but they'll
write outcasts anyone get one 100%
correct and what do you say about that
movement so that is an awesome question
so are you Lindsay and I wrote everyone
every wrote wrote a paper again
privileges the original sin for the left
so but there is one fundamental
difference you're you're having Shermer
and Prager coming to the studio and
debate and it's going to be civilized no
one's going to punch each other they
have fundamental actually very
fundamental just moral disagreement and
finally there one of them Prager Bryant
that you cannot have morality without
God and and Shermer believes the
complete opposite so this is powerful
stuff I fav agree and they're gonna have
a dialogue yeah about that I not going
to score I don't know if it's a debate I
I don't really I'm not a fan of it
having a conversation is much better
but so so you have the same mechanisms
in the in this new secular religion you
have privilege which is a type of
original sin you have blasphemy laws
which are political correctness well
let's just really clear that yeah so
when you say that privilege is the
original said that's like saying Jesus
died for your sins basically like your
if you were born white and yeah
cisgendered had a recited all that [ __ ]
that you are yeah that you are there's
nothing you can did yeah - okay and this
is the part that except now this is a
part that's the mind blow and this is
the part that makes me unbelievably
sympathetic to Christians in particular
as opposed other religious that's really
changed my mind significantly Christians
have a Redemption narrative these people
have no Redemption narrative if you're
privileged that's it you're [ __ ] like
you there's no redemption from you you
can now yard verse yeah yeah yeah so
there's something about being able to be
redeemed these people don't have and
that's why you see these vitriolic
attacks they are merciless on other
people on the left eating other people
on the left the oberus you know the
snake that eats itself yeah so we're
okay along there yeah so yes so it is a
new secular religion and they have maybe
we have modules in our brain I don't
know and maybe it's covariant there with
culture there are things in the culture
and act in our brain and we have the
same thing we have in jonathan highness
it talked about so we have purity versus
sanctity maybe we have you know ways of
interpreting reality but make no mistake
this is a secular religion and when you
call out the empress for having no
clothes you that is that you have
committed you are in trouble
[Music]
you